[Music]
hi guys it's Jen I hear a Happy New Year
this year I want you to move daily
remember a short workout it's better
than no workout okay so this workout is
a seven-minute workout which I want you
to do first thing in the morning once
you get out of bed before you head into
the shower get this workout done you
don't even need any shoes on you don't
even need your sports bra on it's a
low-impact workout so get sweaty and
then head into the shower what you'll
need is a pair of light weight dumbbells
if you don't have a dumbbells you can
make your own dumbbells or if you're a
beginner do the workouts without any
tangles so let's get started
and let's start your year strong so I'm
using three kilos each you can use
between one to three kilos again if
you're a beginner do this workout
without any dumbbells so the first
workout is going to be a squat and a
press so then shoot it with a pot two
hosts pointed forward give me a nice
deep squat push your butt back and if
you come up press up to work on your
shoulders okay let's go deep squat and
press up nice so use the strength from
your lower body to help you press the
dumbbells right up very good squat push
your butt back into a nice deep low
squat and press up work on those
shoulder muscles we want to tone your
lower body and also your upper body good
keep going three more seconds last one
and rest it out second workout dumbbell
punches so it's another kickboxing move
okay so stand shoulder width apart again
toes pointed forward I just want you to
twist and give me a nice left and right
punch okay ready
let's go punch left and right remember
to keep the dumbbells up do not drop it
down this is not a great to work on your
arms okay
punch and twist your hips move your
waist to work on your core as well good
keep punching
straight ahead look straight at your
target good
don't drop the dumbbells now few more
keep going start your new year and your
morning strong and wrapped it up lunch
twist okay so back to lower body so it's
good to be upper body and lower body
stand face forward give me a nice lunge
back
okay and twist to the opposite side
alternate good lunch twist back step
back and twist
so keep the dumbbell close to your core
good lunge and twist lunge and twist
bring them close good work on those core
work on your waist work on your legs
very nice so each movement will work on
multiple muscles keep lunging and
wrapped it up now let's get down onto
the floor and let's get into Superman to
push-up okay
you can use one jungle for this right
onto your floor onto Matt's okay
Superman's lift the dumbbell up push up
good flip it up push up very nice up
grease your lower back push up if this
is difficult do without the dumbbell and
just push up choose your option and up
keep going as you progress lift and up
okay lift and push up and rest it out
alright let's get back down onto our
lower body kneel to squat so you just
hold it down Bell
start low okay start in a low new
position and I want you to just come up
to a low squat the goal is to keep your
body low at all times okay nice and come
up you want to place the dumbbell on
your shoulders you can okay low
and always maintain low do not come up
the whole goal is to really work on your
thighs keep going left and down let's go
right and down you should start to feel
your heart rate and rest it up
now let's stand up shake it all it's a
bit let's get it to plank row okay so
let's get back down onto the floor right
in a plank row start in a high plank
okay give me one nice tuck in and out
left right that's one okay tuck in and
out left right good again always
maintain a nice flat plank good in and
out
row row this is one of my favorite
workouts
it really works on your core and also it
gives you nice back few more don't stop
now
your heart rate your muscles and back up
alright we're not dropping the dumbbells
just yet okay next workout is going to
be to work on your shoulders so site
raises okay so give me a nice L raise
okay up open up back down close it open
up down and close gate one two three
four four movements one two three four
keep your body straight back straight
and tighten your core
okay up two three four keep going up two
three four
very nice one last one and oh my god I
can really feel my shoulders but this
right down shake it out a little bit
alright and now let's get down onto the
floor let's do white V tucks alright so
down onto the floor like flat down okay
grab one dumbbell crunch up open up to a
wide V okay good and open up to a wide V
very nice split it point your toes
open up good keep going you will really
feel your upper your lower abs and also
a little bit on your inner thighs
keep going very nice good whoo work on
those ABS for the new year now back up
turn over into plank right okay get into
a nice solid plank right arms down sugar
whip okay into a nice plank and all I
want you to do is rock forward and back
for the next thirty Seconds good
remember no packing but no dipping your
low back straight line and rock forward
and back very very good keep going keep
rocking good job small movement but you
would really feel your muscles your deep
muscles nice and now one last workout
let's get back up and let's just do a
really simple squat hole okay right
again back to exercise number one shoot
it with a pot hold it down buster
challenge yourself I wanted to get into
a low squat and just hold it for 30
seconds or even longer if you want to
nice just hold it
do your muscles feel but screaming feel
your sweat dripping feel your upper body
tighten your core breathe in breathe out
okay bring your heart rate back down
this is the last workout and you are
done well done guys now that you're
sweaty cool down for a little bit and
then head into the shower and you will
have an amazing day ahead
so this is what I want you to do for the
first week do one set second week
challenge yourself and go to two sets
week three three sets and the final week
four sets so I want you to make this
next four weeks you're challenged to
move every single day okay do this
workout I trust you will see the
difference your body would start to tone
up you will start in this way and you
will have much higher energy so be sure
to share this workout again friends to
join you in this challenge like this
video subscribe to my youtube channel
check out a more workout videos and also
workout challenges on my youtube channel
don't forget to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new
workout video Happy New Year and I'll
see you all the best